Just to stay with him for a moment.
He's painted as the great defender of freedom.
It's possible that your country,
Canada,
and certainly my country,
Australia would have not continued as free societies had it not been for that
man courageously standing at a time when so few did.
He wasn't.
The inventor of freedom.
Freedom is,
we understand it and I want to unpack that a bit.
Something very,
very few people in very few cultures down through the ages and even today I've
ever really experienced.
Oh well,
yes,
Ben.
Partly because we're afraid of it,
I would say.
I mean
people think of freedom as the ability to implement your whim and freedom opens
up that as a possibility,
but sustainable freedom,
that isn't what it's about at all.
It's about,
it's primarily about responsibility.
It's about determining which load you're going to pick up and carry.
That's the proper definition of appropriate freedom.
It's not grout DM gratification of instantaneous impulse.
It's self evident that that doesn't work.
Two year olds do that and that's why they can't live in the world.
They can't organize themselves across time.
They can't sacrifice the moment for the future and the more sophisticated you
get,
I suppose in some sense the more you're able to do that and then your freedom
becomes the freedom to choose the proper responsibility.
And that's not,
that's also not something that we've been good at communicating to young people.
If we talk to them about responsibility,
we don't generally do it in a finger wagging sort of way.
It's like,
well you're breaking the rules,
you're a bad person and,
and,
and well that may be true because people break the rules and there's no shortage
of badness in people.
But the,
the proper message for young people is to say,
well,
no,
you don't understand you,
you want to take on responsibility,
you want to take on the heaviest load that you can conceive of that you might be
able to move because it gives your life nobility and purpose and that offsets
the tragedy.
And,
and,
and not only psychologically,
not only does it offset it psychologically because you have a purpose and
something to wake up for,
right.
And to face the difficulties of the day,
but also because if you face the difficulties of the day properly,
you actually ameliorate suffering not only in the psychological sense,
but because you make the world at least a less terrible place.
And that's something,
right?
To move things away from hell is something,
even if you're not,
you know,
self evidently moving forthrightly to heaven too,
to move things away from the worst they can be as well.
That's a noble goal in and of itself.
So [inaudible] and young people are starving for that idea.
It's very interesting to watch.
As I look at it
seems to me that that acton had it right.
Freedom properly understood,
needs to be seen as a negative and as a positive.
The negatives is,
is this sort of concept of freedom from fear,
addiction,
persecution,
Karen tyranny,
uh,
in a personal and then,
um,
freedom to be used to reach your potential.
But it seems to me that what's missing is an understanding that freedom exercise
within a framework of responsibility.
Are you doing what you ought?
We'll guarantee you ongoing freedom for yourself and fuel and neighbors freedom
exercised in a way that confuses it with license tends to destroy freedom.
In fact,
you could even go so far as to say that misunderstood freedom turns out to be
its own worst enemy.
Uh Huh.
Well that's,
that's the,
that's the difficult distinction between freedom of the moment and,
and freedom of,
of the,
the freedom with everything taken into account.
And I remember real admirer of the work of John Piaget.
Piaget is a developmental psychologist and few people know the world's most well
known developmental psychologists and few people know that he was actually
motivated in his intellectual pursuits by the desire to reconcile science with
religion.
That was what his driving force from the time that he was a young man,
you wouldn't know that even necessarily by reading his writings because it's
implicit rather than explicit in them.
But he,
he,
he has a different model of what constitutes morality than,
than Freud.
Freud's model is combative.
It's sort of the superego as tyrant.
So the superego would be the strictures of society,
the ID,
the biological impulses.
And the eagle crushed between those.
Right?
So the ego is this thing that's crushed between nature and culture.
And so it's a really,
it's a tense and combative model of the Human Psyche and there's something about
it that's,
that's,
that's accurate because some of the restrictions that are put on your impulse
gratification are imposed on you in a,
in,
in a sense to radically.
But Piaget's perspective was much more
optimistic and I think much more accurate.
He noticed that as children organize themselves spontaneously as they developed,
especially within the confines of their own spontaneous play,
they didn't so much subsume art or inhibit their dark and aggressive impulses as
make them sophisticated and transform them into universally acceptable games.
So for Piaget,
a game that a group of children were playing,
that all of them were playing voluntarily and that was going well and that they
all wanted to continue playing was a microcosm of society and literally a
microcosm of society.
The reason the children were playing those games was to practice being
productive members of society.
And he felt that the appropriate game tended towards what he described as an
Nyquil abraded state.
So in acrylic graded state would be a game that you'll play because you've
decided it's a good game,
but that you can play with others because they've also decided that it's a good
game.
And so that can work at the individual level and at the familial level and at
the social level.
And if you get all those things working simultaneously,
then you have a sustainable enterprise.
And it's,
it's predicated not so much on the,
on the,
uh,
inhibition of impulse or on the regulation of it,
but of the integration of impulses into a,
into a pattern of being that gratifies them on a relatively permanent basis.
So,
you know,
if you want to go to university and become a physician,
I think there's a lot of sacrifice of impulsive gratification that goes along
with that.
But if you become a physician,
then it's a noble enterprise.
People support you socially and all of the needs that you need to have
fulfilled.
We'll also be fulfilled by that enterprise.
Well,
that's a way better model.
And so it's strange that the maximum freedom comes with the adoption of a
discipline and then also the adoption of responsibility that frees you up and
everyone else around you in the long run.
And if you explain that to people,
especially in this day and age,
when they'd be fed a never ending diet of idiot rights and freedoms,
they're immediately on board with it because they know and know that most of the
meaning that people experience in their life as a consequence of adopting
responsibility.
So they're starving for that.
Our idea to be articulated.